hello and welcome to this video bit of a
late start there and car shops my
opponent going d4 for a change go for
Queen's Gambit exchange yeah really
like practice all but in those openings
played lots of lots of ephors recently
yeah you can also go to h4 sorry maybe
that is not so precise we should reform
yeah but all in all it's a fairly normal
now positioned for the cows but this
Queen's Gambit exchange structure night
a six know in one word no I don't think
that you can afford that
let's see how to do that Oh cam the see
porn is the target point
I wonder if you should call c5 now maybe
you should do that
of course then d5 is a weakness as well
it's but that's probably less of an
issue than the c6 bond I need to be
precise now if I move the Knight to a4
which looks kind of normal then 94
becomes more of a moral thing 6 so 94 g6
is what he tries to play
[Music]
can also go here night f4 and then
possibly to d3 I mean getting the night
closer to the other side of the board as
maybe an idea simply because the the
advantage there is already that big that
I just need to make sure that I'm not
getting mated really ok night f4f 695
it's not super convincing
ruk g6 I can play Knight f4 awesome and
it's not a problem
maybe you look at six
ah yeah name not happier not happy
g5 I think Knight age five is still okay
but not really not does it I didn't play
well after big after Knight 86 the game
should be just over and as you can see
quite clearly it isn't okay I need to
move the Queen to eat who may be
attacking a sex and getting a little bit
closer to the Kings side not sure that a
six is very relevant but closer to the
Kings side is very lightly relevant
okay now Knight 9595 there is c5
hmm
it's really amazing how I managed to
misplay this position so much
covering f3i just looks very shaky route
g6 a snide edge form so I can trade here
and trying to go to deform
and check if I play a three will
probably take it
King f1 through h6 and it's it's not not
nice
trying to play a queen a g5 they don't
have much time here left
as ideas to play ruk h2 yeah that is
just so terrible I mean night a six it's
just like a triple question mark move
really and I lose this game this is just
the worst terrible absolutely terrible
you know what you are how do I make sure
that that I'm not checkmated this is the
only concern like some silly check made
happening
okay 92 I'm not sure I mean but I don't
think this can be told so terrible and
the engine is giving me just a winning
position that's not a surprise
this should be winning 95 we need to you
know taking on a sixer
that's pop yeah you can probably take
them but okay it's it's so terrible yes
to take and this is a minute she loses
position
great Queen d2 d 4 it feels logical I
have three here that is a good move
let's stop strip off completely and then
then they okay and that is probably
probably not so difficult then however
here and that is still not not very
intuitive that you give up age three and
then get this ending coup D to was my
move Queen yeah this is the mistake okay
yeah of course if I do this I mean then
he has to go back of course or trade
Queens and okay if the Queen's are
traded I'm probably winning I didn't
want to give up this pawn but this is of
course just idiotic
yeah
and now here he's already queen h5 was
better than this but it's already
practically speaking not not offensive
on Luke c6 was still saving me maybe
that they cannot cannot hold this dad it
was that was terrible
yeah I burnt burn too much time maybe I
don't know and sometimes have this
psychological issue that when somebody
play's a move like 96 which is just
plain ridiculous really and I just kind
of think okay now we can only lose a few
blunders stuff and I'm kind of like I
know that I'm sure I'm losing if they
look totally terrible and I mean not
look at many just like you know
basically 90s success yeah like I'm
giving you everything I'm just happy to
be losing and the only way I know that I
can spoil this is my own idiotic play
and sometimes really recognize that I'm
getting into a self-fulfilling
prophecies there and think for a long
time for like however can they do to to
swindle me and so on and then you you
spend too much time and at the end you
really get swindled I mean none of those
moves here were particularly difficult
it's just like I could have played them
much quicker I mean here it was still
okay but actually 27 seconds now it
shouldn't be the case you shouldn't be
so much time down then for him anyway
thanks for watching